Pas de bruit. Pas de vibration.
Les voitures électriques ont vraiment
un petit côté futuriste
et ça tombe bien parce que
ce sont les voitures de demain.
Et déjà d'aujourd'hui !
Ah, t'es là toi ?
Regarde devant toi !
C'est ce que je fais puisque
je parle de la voiture électrique
et vous allez voir que se déplacer
à la seule force de l'électricité
ça ne s'est pas fait en claquant des doigts !
T'as raison, je sens rien.
Alors là, tu dépasses vraiment les bornes !
Suivez-moi, on rentre à l'atelier
je vais vous expliquer comment
fonctionne une voiture électrique.
Faire bouger des objets
avec de l'électricité.
À la fin du 18e siècle, cette expérience
est devenue une attraction
très répandue dans
les cabinets de curiosités.
Un fantasme même qui
tourne parfois au fantastique !
Tenez, à la fin des années 1770,
Luigi Galvani,
dont le nom est attaché
à l'histoire de l'électricité,
constate que les cuisses d'une grenouille
se contractent violemment
sous l'action d'un courant électrique.
Son neveu va plus loin,
il réalise la même expérience
sur un cadavre humain qui,
sous l'effet du courant, se redresse.
L'expérience réalisée en public
fait grand bruit à l'époque
elle aurait dit-on inspiré Mary Shelley
pour son roman Frankenstein.
Euh… je ne vais peut-être pas rester là moi !
L'histoire des sciences, c'est amusant.
Parfois même effrayant !
Mais la découverte
qui va tout bouleverser
c'est le lien entre électricité et magnétisme.
En 1820, Hans Christian Oersted
Oersted ?
Oui, je sais, on ne parle pas
suffisamment de ce personnage.
Oersted découvre donc qu'un courant
électrique circulant dans un conducteur
a le même effet qu'un aimant, démonstration :
ici, l'aiguille de la boussole indique le Nord.
Elle est attirée par le pôle
magnétique de la Terre.
Quand un courant électrique circule
dans le fil conducteur qui passe à proximité.
L'aiguille est déviée.
C'est parce que le courant électrique
génère un champ magnétique.
On recommence ?
Contact, champ magnétique, déviation !
C'est la naissance de l'électromagnétisme
une des plus grandes découvertes de notre histoire.
Tous les grands savants de l'époque
vont alors plancher sur le sujet
Michael Faradet, James Clerk
Maxwell ou encore Nikola Tesla.
Tous, vont contribuer
à théoriser et à expérimenter
ce nouveau champ de recherche
et une des conséquences de tout cela
c'est l'invention du moteur électrique.
Et oui, l'électricité ne fait pas que
bouger des cuisses de grenouilles.
En l'associant à des aimants, on peut envisager
de mettre en mouvement beaucoup de choses.
Venez voir.
Comme avec la boussole, nous avons ici
un fil conducteur en jaune
mais cette fois-ci, il est enroulé un bon
nombre de fois sur lui-même
pour former ce qu'on appelle une bobine.
Cela permet d'augmenter l'intensité
du champ magnétique produit
par le passage de courant.
Cette bobine est reliée de chaque côté
à 2 axes conducteurs eux-mêmes
posés sur un petit socle conducteur.
Et oui, entre tout ce beau monde,
il faut que le courant passe.
Petite subtilité, sur chacun des axes,
une partie a été isolée, la partie blanche.
Ceci afin de simuler un courant alternatif.
Enfin, dernière pièce essentielle
l'aimant qui lui exerce déjà naturellement
un champ magnétique.
Il va interagir avec celui que la bobine va générer.
Voilà, il ne reste plus qu'à brancher et approcher l'aimant et donner une petite pichenette de départ.
Grâce à son champ magnétique,
notre bobine est attirée
puis ne l'est plus, puis à nouveau attirée, et ainsi de suite !
Alors comme je vous le disais, ici, le passage du courant se coupe régulièrement au lieu d'alterner
nous n'inversons donc pas le champ
magnétique de la bobine
qui serait alors attirée puis repoussée.
Mais au bout du compte, ça fonctionne
quand même pas mal !
Il ne lui manque plus que des roues à mon moteur.
Oui, enfin, il manque encore un volant,
une carrosserie, des sièges !
Oula, pas si vite !
Revenons à mon petit moteur.
Il fonctionne grâce à une pile électrique
mais à l'origine
les piles ne ressemblaient pas du tout à cela, mais à cela.
Une succession de disques de cuivre
et de zinc séparés par un tissu imbibé
de saumure, empilés les uns sur les autres.
D'où le nom de "pile".
Pas très pratique et surtout pas très puissante…
Et il était beaucoup plus difficile qu'aujourd'hui de stocker une source d'énergie électrique conséquente.
La suite, nous la connaissons, le charbon
et les énergies fossiles prennent le dessus
elles sont relativement faciles
à stocker et il suffit de les brûler
pour tirer une grande quantité d'énergie.
Mais comme vous le savez, ces énergies
commencent à poser quelques problèmes
et pas des moindres : pollution, réchauffement climatique,
sans parler d'un éventuel épuisement à venir.
De leur côté, le stockage de l'énergie électrique
et son utilisation ont fait de gros progrès.
Justement,
c'est ce que j'essayais de te dire !
Eh bien on t'écoute !
Si on ouvre le capot, et bien le moteur à beau fonctionner
sur le même principe, il n’a pas vraiment la même tête que le tiens.
Celui-ci a une puissance de 33 kilowatts.
C'est en gros l'équivalent de 45 chevaux.
Ce n'est pas une voiture de course, mais c'est nettement
suffisant pour arpenter tous les chemins
de la route de campagne à l'autoroute
en passant par les voies urbaines.
Et en plus, il ne faut jamais oublier que
les voitures électriques sont plus dynamiques
que les voitures thermiques.
Toute la puissance du moteur
est immédiatement disponible.
Tiens, au fait, il fait combien le tien ?
Oh, je dirais un demi poney ?
Oui au mieux.
Et pour alimenter tout ça, la batterie est si volumineuse
qu'elle ne se trouve pas ici, mais sous les sièges.
Sous la banquette arrière
et placée à cet endroit
elle permet de stabiliser le véhicule et
elle aussi n'a plus rien à voir avec les pile de Volta.
Effectivement, du chemin a été parcouru.
Alors aujourd'hui, les batteries ne sont plus composées
de pièces de cuivre et de zinc
séparées par des tampons imbibés de saumure
mais de lithium et de phosphate de fer
trempant dans un électrolyte.
Pour autant, le principe reste le même.
Comme tout ce qui nous entoure,
ces matériaux sont constitués d'atomes.
Un atome, c'est un noyau autour
duquel se baladent des électrons.
Pour produire de l'électricité, on fait circuler ces électrons.
Alors, dans le cas de notre batterie,
ils vont se déplacer de l'anode en lithium
qui a des électrons à revendre,
vers une cathode en phosphate de fer
qui, elle, a tendance à attirer les électrons.
Dès que le circuit électrique se ferme,
tout se mette en mouvement.
Dans l'anode, les atomes de lithium cèdent
des électrons qui se dirigent vers la cathode
en empruntant le fil conducteur.
Ils produisent ainsi un courant électrique.
Dans le même temps, un déséquilibre est crée.
Les atomes de lithium dépossédés
d'une partie de leurs électrons
deviennent des ions,
des ions lithium positifs.
Ils vont alors quitter l'anode,
passer dans les électrolytes.
Mais du côté de la cathode, l'équilibre aussi
est rompu par cet afflux d'électrons.
Il est alors vite rétabli par l'arrivée
des ions lithium positifs
en provenance de l'électrolyte.
Et l'avantage d'une batterie au lithium,
c'est qu'on peut stocker beaucoup d'électrons.
Typiquement sur une voiture comme celle-ci
on peut parcourir jusqu'à 300 kilomètres en ville
et 230 sur les routes.
Mais bon, au bout d'un moment, il faut
quand même bien passer à la prise.
Oui quand même, c'est de la science !
Pas de la magie.
Pour la recharge, c'est assez simple,
il suffit d'inverser le processus.
Les électrons arrivent cette fois-ci du secteur
et se dirigent vers l'anode.
L'équilibre est à nouveau rompu.
Au même moment, dans la cathode
les atomes de lithium perdent des électrons
et vous connaissez la chanson
ils se transforment en positif.
Il quittent la cathode, passent
dans l'électrolyte
et viennent s'installer dans l'anode.
L'équilibre global est à nouveau rétabli.
Alors concrètement, il y a plusieurs
manières de recharger la batterie.
Le plus simple, c'est à la maison,
sur une prise du secteur.
L'intensité du courant est modéré, mais cela suffit
amplement pour charger la voiture la nuit par exemple.
Il y a aussi des solutions dites renforcées, plus sécurisées
et plus rapides que l'on peut installer chez soi.
Enfin, il y a la charge rapide, celle qu'on peut effectuer
sur les bornes de stations-services
et sur les aires d'autoroute notamment.
Cette fois, l'intensité du courant est telle
que l'on peut effectuer une charge à 80% en une petite heure.
C'est pratique quand on fait de longs trajets.
Il y a d'ailleurs de plus en plus de bornes.
Mais attention, il ne faut pas non plus
systématiser au quotidien ce type de charge
effectivement, le réagencement des ions
lithium dans la batterie
est un peu plus chaotique,
ce qui l'use prématurément.
Et oui, une batterie n'est pas éternelle.
Elle s'use plus ou moins vite
au bout d'une dizaine d'années.
En général, il faut la changer
mais on progresse
dans le sens d'une utilisation et surtout
d'une production plus responsable de ces batteries.
On développe des circuits de recyclage
ou la réutilisation.
Tenez, à défaut de pouvoir continuer
à propulser de gros véhicules
certaines batteries peuvent par exemple alimenter
des deux-roues, des appareils électroménagers
ou même stocker l'énergie des panneaux solaire.
Enfin, tant qu'à faire, l'idéal
c'est d'avancer vers un système de production
d'électricité toujours plus durable.
L'autre bonne nouvelle,
c'est que cette technologie progresse.
Et donc leur coût diminue.
Plus on invente et développe dans le domaine de l'électrique,
plus cette technologie se démocratise
et devient accessible au plus grand nombre.
En attendant, notre intérêt à tous,
c'est d'utiliser le moins d'énergie possible.
En se déplaçant à pied
ou à vélo !
Par exemple mais ce n'est pas toujours possible.
Heureusement, la plupart
des voitures électriques
rechargent déjà leurs batteries en roulant.
Lors des ralentissements, l'énergie est récupérée
pour produire de l'électricité.
Un peu comme une dynamo, au lieu d'utiliser
de l'énergie pour faire tourner une manivelle.
Je fais tourner une manivelle
pour produire de l'énergie.
Un autre avantage, c'est que le moteur électrique
est par nature plus efficace
et dynamique qui a moteur thermique.
Le mouvement rotatif du moteur
est directement transmis aux roues
sans passer par une série de pistons.
Moins de déperditions d'énergie, pas de problème
de sous régime, plus de réactivité
il n'y a même pas besoin de boîte de vitesses.
Une réduction du nombre de pièces qui permet
aussi en théorie de limiter les sources de pannes.
Ah ! Je crois que notre correspondant
veut nous parler.
Allo Jamy ?
J'ai fait tout comme tu m'as dit,
j'ai rajouté des roues, des piles
mais c'est pas encore ça visiblement.
Bon bah… je vais rentrer avec la grande.
Allez, c'était la dernière prise.
Salut les Epicurieux.